have you been in a truffle
i was told that i i have been i don't
know how wait you lived with them yeah
my last relationship before bobby was
with two men
this i heard this is fascinating like
yes how did it work like how'd the guys
not have any ego oh they did
one guy would
be crying in a corner
because
he came and now he has to watch the
other guy
so in the beginning it was very testy
but i think that ultimately it was one
of those situations where
um
um
i just can't believe guys like do i know
these guys
no one was a very cute math teacher and
the other is a pediatric nurse
you don't know them that makes sense
that is some loser [ __ ]
which one was crying the most which one
was crying the most be honest no i'm
joking no one was crying i think that
you know like you can share yeah i heard
this no way
look if the girl is that special yes
obviously obviously very special okay
yeah you don't think you can handle two
guys i can from from hearing the stories
to be fair it was [ __ ] exhausting
from the
emotional end of it because we shared a
home we shared a life we traveled
together
um the sex part was just a you know a
tiny thing in that relationship because
like you still have to have a
relationship with these people and
that's
two people's emotions you're taking care
of did you start with one and i started
with one so
oh this is hard thank you for asking
this question an hour in
see how it developed go ahead yeah this
is i was with one for about two and a
half years i met the other person he
became a friend of the both of us
one day it turned into a hey
you know
let's see if you know we could just have
i asked
i asked him i was like would you be down
if he like joined
was he in the room
he was he had spent the night he was in
the shower and we were having sunday
morning sucks
and i remember just saying like
i was a little manipulative in the sense
that he was already inside me when i
asked a little
you know i didn't ask beforehand he was
the crier carlos gonna bank on this pay
attention pay attention to what's going
on right now wait that's so smart i've
never asked for something when they were
inside yeah you did to not come
this is crazy so he's inside you you go
yeah you say what if we asked fred
what's the guy's name fred fred to have
sex with us right and then
he thought that that was a good idea
um
probably not like but he had [ __ ] brain
you got to ask what you want for no when
a guy has [ __ ] brain no he didn't
question the last two and a half years
of your relationship no
no so that's where it started wow you
guys are dumb when you have fun in your
brain no we're smart no
i would have pulled out and covered you
with it and then said hey come on in
fred do your thing
mop up
that is crazy but then it kind of how
did you ask did he know that you kind of
had a crush on him did you guys discuss
that at all no i knew that that guy
thought i was attractive i just know i
mean it's like he was a friend of all of
ours but it's like i was a little cocky
in a sense i'm like he's not going to
turn this down i don't know why i
thought that i just thought that
and from there it became this sort of
yeah this friendship and i lived with
you guys and i broke up with them at the
same time
and
how the [ __ ] did he agree to this
can we call him he
we have a joke on our show that every
time kalila calls the next day they
answer like they were sitting by the
phone waiting
hello princess
um yeah but it really wasn't as big of a
deal as you would think it was very
yeah it was a regular it felt regular
for me
nah that's how a dom is
yeah that man is broken broken but are
you the kind of guy that like really
bothers yes whatever whatever the
question you're asking is you're asking
it as if you don't know the answer
already
are you the kind of guy that like it
really bothers you knowing the previous
partners of the woman you're with are
you i don't even
i don't even
know they exist
nobody
that's a good answer if that's true that
you're like you can just block it out
and don't give a [ __ ] but you have to
know no no i i want to know nothing real
that's i think don't tell me anything
that's great yeah you are and me we
start this thing and i don't care what
happened before me i don't care
because while the things that happened
in your life before
not just like partners you've been with
but like the things have happened you're
like i'm not judging you for any of
those things we start now those things
are going to inform your behavior in our
relationship and when that kind of stuff
comes up tell me so i understand what
i'm dealing with but i'm giving you
clean slate i don't want to enter this
relationship with you and then like have
all these preconceived notions because
of what you've been with let me accept
you for you and let's build some [ __ ]
and then when you see my [ __ ] up stuff
and then i tell you hey this is probably
why i do that then you go okay i
understand that that's fine that's not
about me that's your thing but let me
learn
don't give me all the messed up things
that you've got going on and then i'm
gonna be looking for those things every
time we're in a fight oh you're just
doing this because what about if i'm
gathering intel and i'm asking and i'm
prodding and i'm prying into your life
hey who did you date what time you're
not telling really nope
wow a date in the mall
you don't want to go here yeah that's a
role play this is bad yeah
no but yeah it's bad nothing but harm
comes from this yeah i i think you're
actually like stop asking the questions
and as a man i think we have to know
which questions you don't really want to
know the answer to
ooh
that's delicate
it's delicate that who did you [ __ ] yeah
who of these people did you [ __ ]
i don't i didn't [ __ ] anybody i'm a
virgin i [ __ ] them all or i [ __ ]
none of them yeah and it's simple as
that and you don't want to know because
you want to know like like we want to
have dessert
afterwards you're going to feel shitty
that you did it and that's it's the same
exact thing so i got to go we're not
having dessert i could not relate to
this more i ordered rice pudding to my
room last night
and i don't feel good
but during it felt pretty damn good it
was and it was phenomenal yeah yeah yeah
but yeah no don't ask those questions do
not ask them
how many guys have you slept with
how many girls have you slammed
like that my wife i was like i'm not
telling you so you would never live with
two women
that you
like that's not a thing that
any man thinks
live with you
live with two women have sex with two
women
be in a throuple look at look at the
look at the people on the planet that do
that culturally they blow themselves up
mormons and mormons don't really do that
mormons don't really do that they did
sister wives is a literal mormon term
but they don't do it there's like one of
them that does it no they did it there's
like freak little communities like 100
years they did it say again for 100
years you don't know that mark i do you
don't know i do you don't know i do
maybe i'm just a mormon woman
no no no and in all seriousness i could
i would never want that i don't think
any guy wants that because like you said
the majority of the relationship is
managing the emotions that's hard enough
to do with one person
right imagine adding on another another
another you're going to have to i don't
want to disappoint my wife or my partner
i feel horrible when i do it imagine
disappointing for them
yeah
and i think that's when people think
about a throuple they immediately just
like go into like oh what was it
sexually that's all they think about is
like the sexual nature of a relationship
and it's not that that's only like five
percent of it what is it just more bags
yeah
split ran three ways though it's a
little better get a roommate that
doesn't [ __ ] you
wait where do you sleep with the trouble
do all three people sleep in the same
bed no i had one the original boyfriend
was who i slept with and the other guy
had his own room
but occasionally like post-sex we would
maybe
sleep together in the same bed and it's
fun did they ever touch each other never
i wanted them to so badly
why i don't know i just you know was one
of them bigger notch oh wasn't one of
them bigger [ __ ] um one of them was a
black guy
what does that mean um so he was a well
endowed and um was that he started with
or the new year
started with the black guys i was with
him for like five years yeah and then
the second guy was um
he also had a good size stick but he is
a filipino and
yeah filipino good size for filipino or
good
okay husband husband dick husband dick
what does that mean like you know it's a
dick that is neither too big or too
small you can just have every day and
consume yeah goldilocks yeah
yes okay it's good for everyday use yeah
everyday use okay the the black guy was
the guy that you were dating originally
he's probably more comfortable having a
smaller dick
being brought into the relationship
yeah it was racist that he said yes in
the first place yeah cause he's like i'm
not intimidated by that little dick
you're bringing around
if the guy's dick was bigger yeah
forget it no way
you